THE LAST MINUTE WE SCRAPPED OUR
ORIGINAL PLANS FOR TONIGHT’S
SHOW AND WE MOVE THIS ATTRIBUTE
TO THE TOP.
THAT PERSON IS JARED MOSCOWITZ,
THE DIRECTOR OF THE FLORIDA
PATIENT MANAGEMENT.
WE ARE HAPPY TO HAVE HIM ON.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
SIMPLE QUESTION, REPEAT FOR OUR
AUDIENCE IF YOU WOULD, WHAT YOU
TOLD ME ABOUT YOUR EFFORTS TO
GET MASKS FOR YOUR STATE, WHICH
BY THE WAY IS YOUR JOB.
WHAT HAPPENED?
>> THANK YOU, I APPRECIATE YOU
HAVING ME ON.
APPRECIATE YOU FEATURING THE
STORY.
IT’S IMPORTANT FOR ALL THE
HEALTH CARE WORKERS AND NURSES
AND DOCTORS AND FIRST RESPONDERS
ON THE FRONT LINE.
NO, LISTEN, FOR THE LAST SEVERAL
WEEKS WE HAVE HAD LIKE A BOILER
ROOM CHASING DOWN 3M
AUTHORIZED TO SEPARATORS,
BROKERS, REPRESENTING THAT THEY
N95 MASKS COME ONLY GET TO WHERE
HOUSES THAT ARE COMPLETELY
EMPTY.
WHERE BEING TOLD THAT OUR
SHIPMENTS ARE ON CARGO PLANS AND
THE FLIGHTS DON’T EVEN APPEAR.
WE ARE CHASING GHOSTS.
I JUST DECIDED TO TURN UP THE
HEAT AND TELL PEOPLE WHAT IS
ACTUALLY HAPPENING WITH THE N95
MASKS.
3M REACHED OUT TO US TODAY,
THEIR GOVERNMENT RELATIONS FOLKS
WANTED TO HAVE A CONVERSATION
AND I THOUGHT PERHAPS MAYBE WHAT
3M WOULD FINALLY SAY TO ME IS
THAT THEY HAVE MASKS TO SELL ME,
BUT WHAT I ACTUALLY FOUND OUT IS
EVEN MORE FRIGHTENING.
THAT’S WHAT WE EXPECTED, THE
SYSTEM IS COMPLETELY BROKEN.
THE AUTHORIZED DISTRIBUTORS WHO
RIGHT NOW CAN’T TELL ME A
TIMELINE WITH WHEN I WILL
RECEIVE MY MASKS, THE ORDER I
PUT IN A MONTH AGO.
BY THE WAY, THE TERMS AND
CONDITIONS ARE I HAVE TO PAY FOR
THE MASKS AND CAN’T CANCEL MY
ORDER.
3M HAS LOST TOTAL CONTROL.
WHAT I ASKED 3M IS THAT, ARE
THEY AWARE THEY ARE AUTHORIZED
DISTRIBUTORS?
U.S. COMPANIES ARE TELLING ME
THE REASON WHY OUR ORDERS ARE
BEING PUSHED DOWN IS BECAUSE
FOREIGN COUNTRIES ARE SHOWING UP
WITH CASH TO PURCHASE THE
ORDERS.
WHEN I TOLD 3M OF THAT, NOT ONLY
DID THEY DO NOT DISPUTE IT.
I ASKED THEM IF THEY PUT ANY
GUIDELINES TO PREVENT THE
BEHAVIOR AND THE ANSWER WAS NO.
WHEN I ASKED 3M, WHAT IS YOUR
PRODUCTION?
THEY SAID THEY’RE MAKING
10 MILLION MASKS A WEEK.
WHAT I SAID GREAT, I HAVE MONEY
AND I LIKE TO PURCHASE SOME OF
THOSE.
THEY SAID I COULDN’T, THEY HAVE
NO MASKS TO SELL ME.
IT’S CRIMINAL WHAT IS HAPPENING.
I WANT TO SAY SOMETHING VERY
CLEAR, THIS IS NOT ABOUT THE
WORKERS IN THE FACTORIES AND 3M
WHO ARE WORKING 24 HOURS A DAY
TO TRY TO CREATE THIS
LIFE-SAVING PB.
THIS IS ABOUT THE EXECUTIVES WHO
DECIDED NOT TO PUT AMERICA FIRST
AND IT’S GOING TO HAVE
DEVASTATING CONSEQUENCES.
>> Tucker: I JUST WANT TO
ENCAPSULATE WHAT YOU SAID
BECAUSE I WANT THIS TO SINK IN
FOR THE AUDIENCE.
YOU TRY TO GET AN ANSWER AND
YOU’RE IN CHARGE OF PROCURING
THESE FOR THE FIRST RESPONDERS
IN FLORIDA APPEARED TO NOT JUST
SOME GUY OFF THE STREET.
YOUR GOVERNMENT OFFICIAL TRYING
TO HELP THE STATE THAT IS
BECOMING ONE OF THE CENTERS OF
THE OPERA, FLORIDA.
HE BASICALLY GOT THE RUNAROUND.
HE WENT AFTER 3M ON TWITTER AND
THEY RESPONDED.
PEOPLE NOTICED IT AND THEY
RESPONDED AND YOU SAID, WHY
CAN’T I GET IT?
THEY SAID I HAVE NO CONTROL.
OUR DEALERS ARE SELLING SOME OF
THESE MASKS TO FOREIGN COUNTRIES
BECAUSE THEY GOT THERE FIRST AND
THEY’RE PAYING CASH.
YOU SAID, SHOULDN’T YOU TELL
YOUR DISTRIBUTORS TO MAKE A
PRIORITY FOR AMERICA?
FOR THE STATES, THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS, THE
FIRST RESPONDERS, NURSES, EMTS?
THEY SAID NO, WE HAVEN’T DONE
THAT.
IS THAT IF YOUR SUMMARY?
>> NOT ONLY IS NOT A FAIR
SUMMARY, IT’S EXACTLY WHAT HAS
HAPPENED.
THAT IS WHY THE GOVERNOR SAID
IT’S SHADY AS HELL.
3M IS AN ICE CREAM STORE THAT
DOESN’T SELL ICE CREAM.
SINCE WHEN WE HAVE A U.S.
COMPANY THAT DOESN’T SOLVE MASKS
AND I TRY TO OFFER THEM MONEY
AND THEY DON’T SELL THEM TO ME?
I HAVE TO GO THROUGH THEIR
AUTHORIZED DISTRIBUTORS AND
THEIR ONLY EXCUSE IS THAT THEY
DON’T HAVE A PERFECT SYSTEM.
THAT IS GREAT THEY DON’T HAVE A
PERFECT SYSTEM AND I’M RELEGATED
TO MAKING DEALS WITH BROKERS AT
COSTS THAT ARE TEN AND SOMETIMES
20 TIMES THE ACTUAL COSTS OF
THESE MASKS.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, TUCKER,
REGARDLESS OF THE COST OF THIS
POINT, GET IN THE MASK IS THE
MOST IMPORTANT.
WE CAN’T EVEN GET THEM.
>> Tucker: I GUESS FOR ME,
YOUR PRESENT FLORIDA AND IF THEY
SAID I’M SORRY, MICHIGAN GOT
THEIR FIRST OR CALIFORNIA IS ON
THE LIST OR NEW YORK HAS A
MASSIVE OUTBREAK.
THEY NEED THESE MASKS.
I THINK EVERYONE WOULD
UNDERSTAND THAT.
YOU LEARN THAT THESE MASKS ARE
LITERALLY BEING SOLD TO FOREIGN
COUNTRIES IN THE MIDDLE OF A
PANDEMIC FOR WHICH WE ARE
SUFFERING PROFOUNDLY.
I GUESS MICHAEL RAHMAN WHO WAS
THE CEO OF THIS COMPANY WHO IS
DOING SOMETHING ON TV, HE NEVER
TOLD HE DISTRIBUTORS THAT
THIS COUNTRY COMES FIRST.
THAT IS BIZARRE TO ME, IT IS
SHOCKING.
>> THE FUNNY THING IS THAT THAT
IS NOT A RUMOR.
THAT IS NOT SOMETHING THAT WAS
SUGGESTED.
THE THREE TO MY 3M AUTHORIZED
DISTRIBUTORS, THERE’S ONLY 20
COMPANIES, THEY 3M AUTHORIZED
INTERPRETERS ARE TELLING ME
THIS.
THEY’RE SPECIFICALLY SAYING,
LISTEN, WE ARE SORRY ORDER GOT
PUSHED DOWN, BUT THERE ARE FOLKS
SHOWING UP TO THE FACTORIES.
THERE ARE FOLKS SHOWING UP TO
US, CALLING US, PAYING CASH FOR
IT I SAID, WHAT YOU MEAN THERE
ARE FOLKS?
THEY SAID LISTEN, THERE ARE
FOREIGN COUNTRIES WHO DO
BUSINESS DIFFERENTLY UNDER THEIR
SHOWING UP WITH CASH.
THE IDEA THAT AN AMERICAN
COMPANY IS SELLING MASKS AWAY
FROM OUR HOSPITALS COME AWAY
FROM OUR DOCTORS COME AWAY FROM
THE REAL HEROES ON THE FRONT
LINES IS SOMETHING THAT WILL
LONG BE INVESTIGATED AFTER THIS.
IT’S REALLY CRIMINAL WHAT IS
HAPPENING.
I CAN’T, I CAN’T, OTHER
MANAGEMENT DIRECTORS, CEOs OF
HOSPITALS CAN’T GET THIS
LIFE-SAVING PPE BECAUSE A
COMPANY DECIDED TO MAKE A
GLOBALIST DECISION AND NOT PUT
AMERICA FIRST.
>> Tucker: YOU WOULD THINK THE
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS GUY WHO
CALLED YOU TODAY WOULD HAVE
THOUGHT, THIS IS PRETTY
DISGUSTING WHAT I’M DEFENDING.
MAYBE I WILL SEND A MEMO TO
MICHAEL RAHMAN AND SAY HEY,
MR. CEO, YOU SHOULD TELL HER
DISTRIBUTORS TO PUT THE STATE OF
FLORIDA ABOVE SAY, CHINA.
JERRY MOSCOWITZ, I’M THANKFUL
YOU CAME ON TONIGHT.
THAT IS THE MOST VIVID
DESCRIPTION I’VE HEARD.